this guy vince gilligan who wrote you
know breaking bad
he didn't make you audition or anything
no for the for the small prize which is
which is great he was just a fan of
yours it was all this crazy stuff i did
on the show with david cross called mr
show
that he was a big fan of breaking bad
was not a hit
coming out of the box at all and it was
almost canceled after the first two
seasons and
and when i went on the second season i'd
never seen it
really i'd never seen the show i'd only
seen the billboard
with uh walter white in his underwear
and i called
a friend i thought i'd have to call five
or six friends to ask him what is this
thing should i do it
and uh and i was gonna do it just to be
very clear
i was gonna take that cash but call me
crazy bob i would think if i got offered
a job on a tv show
i would go out of curiosity and go watch
the show a couple of episodes no
well i did watch it on the flight oh
[ __ ] albuquerque i popped a dvd into
my little
computer and uh watched ten minutes of
it because i wanted to make sure i
got the tone right i understood it was a
drama right and i also saw that my
character was pretty funny so like how
did the how does it marry up you know
and then of course i dialed it in a lot
more when i got in a room with brian
cranston
and he's [ __ ] doing a master class
10 you know two feet from my face and
i'm like i better amp up my game here
and show up but
i i was uh i i figured it out
do you have to stick to the exact
writing the way it is or will you
call the oh you do no no no no no this
is there's nobody
this isn't comedy your comedy screw-ups
and
fool arounds this is this is adult uh
drama effort right pros um
i got that first script from vince and i
immediately started [ __ ] with it just
like a comedy writer does
i say oh i wouldn't say that oh what if
i said this i started writing all this
garbage
yeah somewhere in the middle of it i
went you know what
hey what if you tried to be an actor
what if you just
tried would would that be okay once in
your life
you [ __ ] clown right and i thought
well i'm not me i'm saul goodman i'm
this guy
and he's chosen to talk this way he's
actually chosen this persona
he tells walter white this is all phony
this is a thing i'm inventing
so why don't i try and and just
really commit to this person who doesn't
talk like me doesn't act like me doesn't
dress like me
he hasn't doesn't have my priorities
let's not do that thing
where you make it easier for you to to
do it but rather you stretch yourself
and
and put yourself and try to really live
in another person's skin who's not you
and then when you do it
when you feel like you nailed it like
you made those words
as written come out and they felt
natural they were right
that's that's the job thing that's cool
about acting